one of the most requested things for me
to do is to talk more about my various
collections in the past I did a
humungous blu-ray update it was my five
hundredth video and ever since then
people have been like can you do more
can you do more I want to know what else
you're getting I see your shelf
expanding Chris what's going on back
there people want to know about my
Nintendo 64 collection behind me some
people actually have been asking me what
are those yellow things behind you I
frown upon those questions I frown upon
them I'm gonna talk about some of the
pick ups I have there I'm going to talk
about some I knew blu-rays and show you
guys some of my new toys and things
behind me I don't always like to call
them toys they're technically toys but I
call them statues and replicas and other
adult names for toys by the way do you
like my new shirt it is an Iron Man
Metroid crossover and I love it
I picked up the wolf of wallstreet
because I just had to and on top of that
it was only $7.99 I also got gravity for
only $7.99 yeah I just saw this one
place that they sell like rental stuff
all the time they put out their movies
for rent and then like three weeks later
they sell them all for like $7.99 s
awesome I also picked up the entirety of
Rocko's Modern Life the entire show on
DVD I don't know if you guys ever
watched this but I grew up with it it's
one of the best cartoons that came out
in the 90s I love this show and it's
also kind of disgusting at times they
got away with a lot more stuff in kids
cartoons when I was a kid and after
seeing the newest one I wanted to go
back and watch How to Train Your Dragon
and my fiance actually picked us up at
Walmart for like 1296 and I forgot how
much I loved this movie because I'd only
seen it the one time in theaters and
this movie really blew me away a movie
that I didn't see when I was a little
little kid but saw eventually like in my
teen years and I realized I loved is
clue it's just one of those movies where
like the whole movie takes place in this
dark creepy mansion it's very funny but
it's also a very cozy movie you know
like you can watch it during a
thunderstorm or something and it just
makes the entire house feel really
creepy and awesome and it has a really
good performance by Tim Curry I picked
up Robin Williams most underrated movie
in my opinion and that is one-hour photo
this movie was directed by Mark Romanek
Robin Williams in this movie develops
pictures for a living and he constantly
develops the photos of a specific family
that he becomes obsessed with it's an
extremely well directed movie and in my
opinion Robin Williams possibly one of
his best performances for sure like it's
not maybe maybe Good Will Hunting it's
his best but this is so close
also I'm ashamed to admit the truthful
about the fact that it wasn't until semi
recently that I saw Evil Dead 2 for the
first time this movie's ingenuity blew
me away Sam Raimi and Bruce Campbell
what they did with this movie was so
incredibly impressive on such a tight
budget they weren't really sure if they
were going to be able to make this
sequel but they got to and it turned out
so awesome I mean yeah some of the
effects are dated but it just has this
charm to it when you watch it now I do
have a video on my channel that I
a while back chronicling my continuing
efforts to collect in ten of 64 games at
that time I didn't have any of the
actual boxes any of the actual manuals
they were in these fake plastic cases
that are meant to look like the cases
now it's a little different I'm
attempting to collect the entirety of
the Nintendo 64 library because that's
what cool people do nowadays apparently
there's only 296 games now that's
actually not that much and so it's
actually a realistic goal behind me are
about 50% of the system so FAR's but
I've gotten to now this is box manual
and cartridge that's what's considered
complete I'm going to share with you
some of the rarest ones I have and talk
to you guys about some of the ones that
I'm really looking forward to getting
I'll just start out for my rarest one
that is clay fighter sculptors cut I
have the box and the game I do not have
the manual this is considered the rarest
item in the Nintendo 64 library it was a
blockbuster rental only exclusive that
meant you couldn't buy it in stores you
could only rent it at Blockbuster so a
billion kids would like touch this and
then the manual would like get boogers
and stuff all over it and so to find it
in good condition it's virtually
impossible sometimes this can go for
like a thousand two thousand dollars
complete the manual is the hardest thing
to find and I do not happen one of my
dreams is to just like find it at a
thrift store or a flea market or
something or somebody has it at a
reasonable price for once but it's very
hard to find at some point I will get it
so I can complete my set but that is my
ultimate want right there is the clay
fighter sculptors cut manual because
that that's crazy right that that's like
you don't really want to pay you know a
thousand dollars for a piece of paper
when you can pay your rent for a few
months you know what I mean so my goal
is to eventually find it at a convention
or something or trade somebody for it
you know but eventually I will find it
now all my boxes you may notice they're
kind of glisteny it's because I have
these box protectors over them these
plastic box protectors I got those from
retro protection calm this guy is so
awesome he's got a eBay store as well he
sold me a lot of them at a really good
deal that guy was very nice to me he
sent me some messages we talked back and
forth
he sells things like manual protectors
and cartridge protectors and box
protectors every single one of these has
them in
they're like for instance my army man
game it just I feel right as a collector
to be able to have them like safe
because well it was my cat one day just
just like pees everywhere I mean you
know that could help definitely check
out retro protection comm and his eBay
store let him know I sent you because if
you're into collecting like I am he'll
give you a good deal for sure another
pretty rare one I have is Conker's Bad
Fur Day
the complete set this is manual box in
game this game is more rare because it
was released way late in the Nintendo 64
lifespan like close to win they had
already transitioned completely over to
GameCube plus it looks like a kids game
but it's rated mature has like bad
language and blood and gore and stuff
it's very funny it was made by rareware
which arguably made the Nintendo 64
because they made like goldeneye perfect
dark banjo kazooie jet force Gemini
Donkey Kong 64 Diddy Kong Racing they
made so many great games this might be
the second or third most rare item on
the Nintendo 64 library and that is
stunt racer another blockbuster
exclusive only available for rental I do
have the Box the manual in the cartridge
and something I'm very happy about
because this is really hard to get your
hands on another blockbuster exclusive
Indiana Jones and the infernal machine
these things are rare these blockbuster
special only games because in a place
you get it was blockbuster and so it
makes it hard to find a good condition
box manual one cartridge so I'm proud to
own a lot of these because as a
collector it's just something that makes
me happy you know I can see so I can
come in here and I can actually see like
things that I used to play as a kid and
actually feel like I have an actual
library of something my friends came
over the other day and they were just
like hey do you have this game as I get
I got it's actually a dream of mine is
like anyone come to my house and be like
do you have that this specific n64 game
I want to play that I play when I was a
kid I'm like I got over here oh we can
play it just you and me
and this is also something I want to
encourage if any of you are fellow
nintendo64 collectors who would like to
trade or get in contact with me about
trading items if I could I do get a lot
of duplicates of things sometimes I do
actually converse with quite a bit of
collectors I'm on the Nintendo age
forums so if they've been want Stu
converse with me about that I'm down you
can email me at Kris stuckman at
gmail.com and we can talk stuff over who
knows I might have something you want
you might have something I want I don't
know the guys may be seeing transformers
age of extinction this Wednesday my
review will be up late Wednesday night
hopefully it's not terrible as always
guys thanks so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck with nice